[Música]
al menos 47 personas han perdido la vida
en un mes de manifestaciones en Perú en
rechazo al gobierno de la presidenta
Dina boluarte la situación sigue siendo
tensa en el sur del país entre tanto una
misión de la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos arribó al país para
investigar denuncias de hechos de uso
excesivo de la fuerza de violencia
luz verde a un nuevo proceso
Constituyente en Chile la cámara de
diputados aprobó por una amplia mayoría
la reforma constitucional con la que
habilita el proceso para redactar una
nueva Carta Magna que se espera sea
refrendada el 17 de diciembre tras el
fracaso en el plebiscito del año pasado
los bolsonaristas echan marcha atrás las
protestas programadas para este
miércoles en Brasilia fueron canceladas
pero la atención sigue en la capital
donde la seguridad fue reforzada ante
los temores de que se repita la toma de
edificios de poderes públicos el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
dijo que los actos antidemocráticos
serán castigados
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias al
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú donde persisten las manifestaciones
contra el gobierno de la presidenta Dina
boluarte al menos 47 personas han muerto
desde el inicio de las protestas en
enfrentamientos entre civiles y las
fuerzas armadas de otra parte arribó al
país una misión de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos para
investigar denuncias sobre las
violaciones a los derechos fundamentales
en la nación informe de Samuel Salgado
familiares de manifestantes muertos en
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas
estatales realizan ceremonias fúnebres
el sur de Perú es el actual epicentro de
la violencia por las protestas contra la
presidenta Dina boluarte quien asumió El
Ejecutivo en reemplazo de Pedro Castillo
destituido por el congreso y detenido
por delitos de Conspiración y rebelión
aquí en la Plaza de la ciudad de juliaca
esta mujer exige justicia por la muerte
de su familiar
acá estamos muriendo queremos todo
justicia queremos estamos pidiendo
renuncia
cierre del Congreso a 41 kilómetros de
juliaca en puno la situación también es
crítica el 9 de enero será recordado
como el día más mortífero en un mes de
protestas la defensoría del pueblo de
Perú reveló que sólo ese día murieron al
menos 17 civiles en enfrentamientos con
la policía lo que hizo reaccionar al
gobierno central que ordenó el toque de
por tres días en puno representantes de
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos llegaron al país para investigar
las protestas y la respuesta del estado
en la visita de observación el
vicepresidente de la cidh estuardo ralón
y el comisionado Joel Hernández se
reúnen con la presidenta de la República
Dina boluarte y altas autoridades para
recibir información del contexto actual
en Perú la atención sigue en todo el
país en el turístico cusco donde se
encuentra Machu Picchu se registraron
nuevos choques entre manifestantes y la
policía Mientras que persiste el llamado
a paro nacional indefinido y el bloqueo
de importantes carreteras como la
Panamericana Sur
en Chile la cámara de diputados dio luz
verde para iniciar un nuevo proceso
Constituyente después del referendo de
septiembre de 2022 en el que no fue
aprobado por los ciudadanos el proyecto
de nueva constitución a diferencia del
primer intento en este habrá
participación política en la redacción
del anteproyecto después será escogido
un consejo popular y el 17 de diciembre
será el día en que los ciudadanos darán
o no su visto bueno a la propuesta Juice
Muñoz nos amplía
la Constituyente de Chile ya tiene hoja
de ruta esto después de ser aprobada la
reforma para un segundo proceso en la
cámara de diputadas y diputados y
definirse el 17 de diciembre como la
fecha para votar por el nuevo plebiscito
todo hacía indicar que el texto sería
aprobado el 13 de diciembre 14 partidos
políticos de izquierda a derecha
llegaron a un acuerdo de verdad creemos
es un gran acuerdo que permite para los
que estuvimos en el rechazo y para los
que estuvieron en la prueba mantener el
camino para tener una buena nueva
constitución a diferencia del primer
intento ahora habrá una comisión de 24
expertos y un comité técnico de 14
juristas todos estos saldrán de la
cámara de diputados y el senado y se
instalarán el 6 de marzo tendrán tres
meses para trabajar en un anteproyecto
el 7 de mayo por votación popular se
escogerán los 50 miembros del Consejo
constitucional tendrán cinco meses para
redactar el nuevo texto son los ajustes
para lograr una nueva constitución
acorde al pueblo chileno como dijo el
presidente Gabriel boric después del no
del 4 de septiembre y los procesos de
siempre tienen retrocesos cuando
quien quiera que sea
se ASUME como vanguardia y pretende ir
más rápido que el pueblo al que
representa
más del 60% de la población rechazó el
texto de la convención constitucional
este órgano fue constituido tras ser
elegido en votación Popular en octubre
de 2020 fue el resultado de las mayores
protestas en la historia de chile con
demandas que concentraban El clamor
popular para cambiar la antigua
Constitución de 1980 promulgada por el
dictador Augusto pinochet
miles de trabajadores del sector público
como educación y sanidad marcharon en
Caracas Venezuela junto a pensionados
exigiendo incremento en sus ingresos fue
el tercer día consecutivo de protestas
en la capital venezolana Ramiro cueva
Barberena tiene los detalles
miles de trabajadores públicos y
jubilados marcharon en el corazón de
Caracas exigiendo mejores salarios y
pensiones que actualmente apenas
equivalen a 7 dólares mensuales
una cifra insuficiente para costear las
necesidades diarias
no puedo ponerme un par de zapatos
nuevos porque eso no me alcanza
son una medicina enferma de los
bronquios y la medicina vale 140 dólares
y yo no lo puedo comprar porque yo no
cobro esto trabajadores de sectores
esenciales como la salud y la educación
también marcharon exigiendo aumentos en
los salarios Aunque aclararon que no
piensan realizar una huelga
estamos hoy aquí en esta concentración
todos los sectores de Salud Educación
los jubilados y pensionados exigiéndole
al gobierno salario dignos tenemos unos
salarios miserables los maestros estamos
ganando ni siquiera para vivir
dignamente
es el tercer día consecutivo protestas
del sector público en Caracas en 2023
junto a los jubilados continúan
reclamando por la homologación del
salario y las pensiones a la canasta
básica además de seguridad social
vamos a Brasil donde las protestas de
Seguidores del expresidente jael
bolsonaro programadas para el miércoles
fueron canceladas sin embargo la
seguridad se reforzó en Brasilia y todos
los caminos que conducen a la Explanada
de los ministerios fueron cerrados a
peatones y vehículos ante los temores
que suscitaba una nueva toma de los
edificios del poder público previamente
desde Río de Janeiro nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sacónne nos
explicaba las medidas adoptadas para
blindar la seguridad del gigante
sudamericano
Brasil se ha blindado hoy ante el riesgo
de que se pudiesen repetir los ataques
violentos del pasado domingo grupos
bolsonaristas estaban amenazando con
volver a las calles para ser
manifestaciones de retomada de poder las
había prevista en Brasilia y también
aquí en Río de Janeiro y muchas ciudades
importantes del país el juez Alexandre
dimorais de la Corte Suprema decidió
accionar toda la maquinaria jurídica y
decidió prohibir la interrupción de las
carreteras y también la invasión de
edificios públicos las penas eran cárcel
o multas de hasta 100.000 reales
equivalentes a 20 mil dólares finalmente
no hubo manifestaciones aquí en Río
tampoco en Brasilia donde se había
cerrado la plaza de los tres poderes y
mientras tanto se ha decidido mantener
alejado del poder al gobernador del
Distrito Federal donde encuentra
Brasilia y vanéis Rocha considerado
culpable de haber permitido los
destrozos del pasado domingo
en Estados Unidos continúa la
controversia por el hallazgo de
documentos clasificados en una antigua
oficina privada del presidente
estadounidense Joe biden sobre una
fuente citada por el informativo de la
cadena mbc asistentes del mandatario
descubrieron un segundo lote de
documentos Aunque el informe no precisa
la cantidad el nivel de clasificación ni
el lugar ni la fecha en la que fueron
encontrados esta denuncia ha provocado
que el presidente sea centro de críticas
porque justamente el mandatario señaló
en reiteradas ocasiones al expresidente
Donald Trump por tener documentos e
información oficial en su residencia de
Mara lago en Florida
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web triple W punto franz24.com
para seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias Gracias por acompañarnos
quédense con nosotros
[Música]